The modern world has an insatiable appetite
for computation, so system architects are
always thinking about ways to make programs
run faster.
The running time of a program is the product
of three terms:
The number of instructions in the program,
multiplied by the average number of processor
cycles required to execute each instruction
(CPI), multiplied by the time required for
each processor cycle (t_CLK).
To decrease the running time we need to decrease
one or more of these terms.
The number of instructions per program is
determined by the ISA and by the compiler
that produced the sequence of assembly language
instructions to be executed.
Both are fair game, but for this discussion,
let's work on reducing the other two terms.
As we've seen, pipelining reduces t_CLK by
dividing instruction execution into a sequence
of steps, each of which can complete its task
in a shorter t_CLK.
What about reducing CPI?
In our 5-stage pipelined implementation of
the Beta, we designed the hardware to complete
the execution of one instruction every clock
cycle, so CPI_ideal is 1.
But sometimes the hardware has to introduce
"NOP bubbles" into the pipeline to delay execution
of a pipeline stage if the required operation
couldn't (yet) be completed.
This happens on taken branch instructions,
when attempting to immediately use a value
loaded from memory by the LD instruction,
and when waiting for a cache miss to be satisfied
from main memory.
CPI_stall accounts for the cycles lost to
the NOPs introduced into the pipeline.
Its value depends on the frequency of taken
branches and immediate use of LD results.
Typically it's some fraction of a cycle.
For example, if a 6-instruction loop with
a LD takes 8 cycles to complete, CPI_stall
for the loop would be 2/6, i.e., 2 extra cycles
for every 6 instructions.
Our classic 5-stage pipeline is an effective
compromise that allows for a substantial reduction
of t_CLK while keeping CPI_stall to a reasonably
modest value.
There is room for improvement.
Since each stage is working on one instruction
at a time, CPI_ideal is 1.
Slow operations - e.g, completing a multiply
in the ALU stage, or accessing a large cache
in the IF or MEM stages - force t_CLK to be
large to accommodate all the work that has
to be done in one cycle.
The order of the instructions in the pipeline
is fixed.
If, say, a LD instruction is delayed in the
MEM stage because of a cache miss, all the
instructions in earlier stages are also delayed
even though their execution may not depend
on the value produced by the LD.
The order of instructions in the pipeline
always reflects the order in which they were
fetched by the IF stage.
Let's look into what it would take to relax
these constraints and hopefully improve program
runtimes.
Increasing the number of pipeline stages should
allow us to decrease the clock cycle time.
We'd add stages to break up performance bottlenecks,
e.g., adding additional pipeline stages (MEM1
and MEM2) to allow a longer time for memory
operations to complete.
This comes at cost to CPI_stall since each
additional MEM stage means that more NOP bubbles
have to be introduced when there's a LD data
hazard.
Deeper pipelines mean that the processor will
be executing more instructions in parallel.
Let's interrupt enumerating our performance
shopping list to think about limits to pipeline
depth.
Each additional pipeline stage includes some
additional overhead costs to the time budget.
We have to account for the propagation, setup,
and hold times for the pipeline registers.
And we usually have to allow a bit of extra
time to account for clock skew, i.e., the
difference in arrival time of the clock edge
at each register.
And, finally, since we can't always divide
the work exactly evenly between the pipeline
stages, there will be some wasted time in
the stages that have less work.
We'll capture all of these effects as an additional
per-stage time overhead of O.
If the original clock period was T, then with
N pipeline stages, the clock period will be
T/N + O.
At the limit, as N becomes large, the speedup
approaches T/O.
In other words, the overhead starts to dominate
as the time spent on work in each stage becomes
smaller and smaller.
At some point adding additional pipeline stages
has almost no impact on the clock period.
As a data point, the Intel Core-2 x86 chips
(nicknamed "Nehalem") have a 14-stage execution
pipeline.
Okay, back to our performance shopping list…
There may be times we can arrange to execute
two or more instructions in parallel, assuming
that their executions are independent from
each other.
This would increase CPI_ideal at the cost
of increasing the complexity of each pipeline
stage to deal with concurrent execution of
multiple instructions.
If there's an instruction stalled in the pipeline
by a data hazard, there may be following instructions
whose execution could still proceed.
Allowing instructions to pass each other in
the pipeline is called out-of-order execution.
We'd have to be careful to ensure that changing
the execution order didn't affect the values
produced by the program.
More pipeline stages and wider pipeline stages
increase the amount of work that has to be
discarded on control hazards, potentially
increasing CPI_stall.
So it's important to minimize the number of
control hazards by predicting the results
of a branch (i.e., taken or not taken)
so that we increase the chances that the instructions
in the pipeline are the ones we'll want to
execute.
Our ability to exploit wider pipelines and
out-of-order execution depends on finding
instructions that can be executed in parallel
or in different orders.
Collectively these properties are called "instruction-level
parallelism" (ILP).
Here's an example that will let us explore
the amount of ILP that might be available.
On the left is an unoptimized loop that computes
the product of the first N integers.
On the right, we've rewritten the code, placing
instructions that could be executed concurrently
on the same line.
First notice the red line following the BF
instruction.
Instructions below the line should only be
executed if the BF is *not* taken.
That doesn't mean we couldn't start executing
them before the results of the branch are
known,
but if we executed them before the branch,
we would have to be prepared to throw away
their results if the branch was taken.
The possible execution order is constrained
by the read-after-write (RAW) dependencies
shown by the red arrows.
We recognize these as the potential data hazards
that occur when an operand value for one instruction
depends on the result of an earlier instruction.
In our 5-stage pipeline, we were able to resolve
many of these hazards by bypassing values
from the ALU, MEM, and WB stages back to the
RF stage where operand values are determined.
Of course, bypassing will only work when the
instruction has been executed so its result
is available for bypassing!
So, in this case, the arrows are showing us
the constraints on execution order that guarantee
bypassing will be possible.
There are other constraints on execution order.
The green arrow identifies a write-after-write
(WAW) constraint between two instructions
with the same destination register.
In order to ensure the correct value is in
R2 at the end of the loop, the LD(r,R2) instruction
has to store its result into the register
file after the result of the CMPLT instruction
is stored into the register file.
Similarly, the blue arrow shows a write-after-read
(WAR) constraint that ensures that the correct
values are used when accessing a register.
In this case, LD(r,R2) must store into R2
after the Ra operand for the BF has been read
from R2.
As it turns out, WAW and WAR constraints can
be eliminated if we give each instruction
result a unique register name.
This can actually be done relatively easily
by the hardware by using a generous supply
of temporary registers, but we won't go into
the details of renaming here.
The use of temporary registers also makes
it easy to discard results of instructions
executed before we know the outcomes of branches.
In this example, we discovered that the potential
concurrency was actually pretty good for the
instructions following the BF.
To take advantage of this potential concurrency,
we'll need to modify the pipeline to execute
some number N of instructions in parallel.
If we can sustain that rate of execution,
CPI_ideal would then be 1/N since we'd complete
the execution of N instructions in each clock
cycle as they exited the final pipeline stage.
So what value should we choose for N?
Instructions that are executed by different
ALU hardware are easy to execute in parallel,
e.g., ADDs and SHIFTs, or integer and floating-point
operations.
Of course, if we provided multiple adders,
we could execute multiple integer arithmetic
instructions concurrently.
Having separate hardware for address arithmetic
(called LD/ST units) would support concurrent
execution of LD/ST instructions and integer
arithmetic instructions.
This set of lecture slides from Duke gives
a nice overview of techniques used in each
pipeline stage to support concurrent execution.
Basically by increasing the number of functional
units in the ALU and the number of memory
ports on the register file and main memory,
we would have what it takes to support concurrent
execution of multiple instructions.
So, what's the right tradeoff between increased
circuit costs and increased concurrency?
As a data point, the Intel Nehelam core can
complete up to 4 micro-operations per cycle,
where each micro-operation corresponds to
one of our simple RISC instructions.
Here's a simplified diagram of a modern out-of-order
superscalar processor.
Instruction fetch and decode handles, say,
4 instructions at a time.
The ability to sustain this execution rate
depends heavily on the ability to predict
the outcome of branch instructions,
ensuring that the wide pipeline will be mostly
filled with instructions we actually want
to execute.
Good branch prediction requires the use of
the history from previous branches and there's
been a lot of cleverness devoted to getting
good predictions from the least amount of
hardware!
If you're interested in the details, search
for "branch predictor" on Wikipedia.
The register renaming happens during instruction
decode, after which the instructions are ready
to be dispatched to the functional units.
If an instruction needs the result of an earlier
instruction as an operand, the dispatcher
has identified which functional unit will
be producing the result.
The instruction waits in a queue until the
indicated functional unit produces the result
and when all the operand values are known,
the instruction is finally taken from the
queue and executed.
Since the instructions are executed by different
functional units as soon as their operands
are available, the order of execution may
not be the same as in the original program.
After execution, the functional units broadcast
their results so that waiting instructions
know when to proceed.
The results are also collected in a large
reorder buffer so that that they can be retired
(i.e., write their results in the register
file) in the correct order.
Whew!
There's a lot of circuitry involved in keeping
the functional units fed with instructions,
knowing when instructions have all their operands,
and organizing the execution results into
the correct order.
So how much speed up should we expect from
all this machinery?
The effective CPI is very program-specific,
depending as it does on cache hit rates, successful
branch prediction, available ILP, and so on.
Given the architecture described here the
best speed up we could hope for is a factor
of 4.
Googling around, it seems that the reality
is an average speed-up of 2, maybe slightly
less, over what would be achieved by an in-order,
single-issue processor.
What can we expect for future performance
improvements in out-of-order, superscalar
pipelines?
Increases in pipeline depth can cause CPI_stall
and timing overheads to rise.
At the current pipeline depths the increase
in CPI_stall is larger than the gains from
decreased t_CLK and so further increases in
depth are unlikely.
A similar tradeoff exists between using more
out-of-order execution to increase ILP and
the increase in CPI_stall caused by the impact
of mis-predicted branches and the inability
to run main memories any faster.
Power consumption increases more quickly than
the performance gains from lower t_CLK and
additional out-of-order execution logic.
The additional complexity required to enable
further improvements in branch prediction
and concurrent execution seems very daunting.
All of these factors suggest that is unlikely
that we'll see substantial future improvements
in the performance of out-of-order superscalar
pipelined processors.
So system architects have turned their attention
to exploiting data-level parallelism (DLP)
and thread-level parallelism (TLP).
These are our next two topics.